been so focused on these movies though
that we haven't been thinking beyond
them
we'll say though that that Fox steel
goes through with Disney there's a lot a
lot more characters to work with all of
a sudden be interesting to do something
like secret Wars or
everybody is Charlie Road to secret Wars
you probably heard the really awesome
Fox Disney news this morning so I'll
explain what's going on what the next
steps are and how long before we
actually see those characters pop up in
the MCU so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos there's a new round of
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway - all
you have to do to enter be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video what
happened this morning is is all the
shareholders from Fox and Disney had to
vote to approve the deal they didn't
quote exact numbers but they said
unanimously people voted yes it was like
99 percent of the shareholders from both
the companies were like hell yeah let's
go
Fox Disney but they expect the deal to
finally close in the first half of next
year which is actually earlier than they
quoted before before they said maybe end
of next summer but now it's looking like
it might actually happen before the
summer so around the time Spiderman far
from home drops in theaters they will
have completed this deal and Kevin Feige
can do whatever it is that he wants to
do with the Fantastic Four and all the
x-men characters so what a coincidence
that spider-man far from home is also
the official beginning of Marvel phase
four prototype for Cap's new shield and
the making it takes a certain amount of
time for them to develop movies though
so I will explain how long it will
actually be from that date before you
could actually see one of those
characters pop up in the MCU there's
still a couple more hoops that Disney
has to jump through in the international
arena everything has been approved in
the United States but what happens now
is the EU has to approve the deal in any
other countries where these two
companies do business when they're
saying they expect the deal to close
during the first half of next year
that's really what takes the amount of
time because it took a while for it to
clear the Justice Department in the
United States now they have to do the
exact same thing in all these other
countries around the world so it sounds
like a bummer but it's not that big a
deal it happens to every big company
when buyouts like this happen
the only real stipulations are is that
Disney has to get rid of a bunch of
local sports TV stations when they buy
everything they're mostly just buying
the IP but Disney will get their cable
network so like they get the FX networks
but they're mostly getting all the shows
that Fox owns so all the TV shows all
those characters all the
movies all those characters film and TV
rights are a little bit different so
it's important that Disney get both of
those recently a lot of you have also
been asking what's going to happen now
with the Fox Marvel movies that they put
into development before this deal
started to go through they've still been
working on x-men Dark Phoenix they're
still working on new mutants they're
developing Deadpool's x-force film
that's supposed to get started later
this year the CEO of Disney has only
specifically talked about the Deadpool
character so I'll explain what he said
about that no one said anything about
what's going on with Dark Phoenix or New
Mutants there been rumors that the films
are kind of in trouble they'd be going
through heavy ratios they've delayed
Dark Phoenix it's being released in
February next year and they still have
not dropped the first teaser so a lot of
people think that evidence is mounting
the Disney is just gonna like take a
mulligan on both of those and put them
on the Shelf and let Kevin Feige reboot
the characters however he sees fit down
the road but officially as of right now
until you hear otherwise it's business
as usual next year for Fox movies so I
still think as of right now they plan to
release Dark Phoenix and if it makes
money great if it doesn't who cares
because they'll just reboot those
characters they spend way less money
making new mutants so there's not that
much risk so I also think that they're
still planning on releasing that to now
they'll probably make more announcements
about that before the end of the year if
we get to December and there's still no
trailer for Dark Phoenix then you really
know something's up
Deadpool though better news for that
franchise the CEO of Disney when they
first announced their attempts to buyout
Fox he said he really loved the Deadpool
franchise they don't intend on
dignifying it or changing it in any
significant way just allowing them to
continue doing what they're doing really
well so this seems like the only
franchise the Disney isn't going to
touch they may just give them access to
Marvel MCU characters like hey if you
want to borrow some for your next
Deadpool movie that's great but we're
not planning on putting Deadpool in a
big Avengers movie anytime soon they
have the x-force movie that Drew Goddard
is working on they're supposed to start
that later this year I think they're
still planning on making that rated-r
Disney has touchtone which is a label
where they've released some of the
rated-r films before because Disney
themselves aren't really known for
making rated-r films but as part of this
big buyout deal if they get a 30% stake
in Hulu they said that their non
family-friendly
tent-like the rated-r hardcore stuff
that will all go to hulu when stuff goes
to streaming because they have that new
disney streaming service were they gonna
do the live-action Star Wars TV show
people have asked Kevin Feige recently
what his plans are for these characters
and he said that he's not allowed to
actively develop any movies until he
gets the call from his overlords at
Disney Kevin Feige has a boss in that
boss has a boss so there are a lot of
people above Kevin Feige that make those
big decisions but he said he's just
waiting for the phone call when someone
says hey the deal is closed you can do
whatever you want to with these
characters now and then he can go tell
riders to start writing these new movies
as of right now he just said that he has
a lot of ideas that he can't make public
I think that Disney has asked all these
directors and the producers not to
speculate openly until the deal has
closed but a lot of them like the Russos
have talked about Secret Wars like oh
man it would be so cool if they get that
Fox deal closed Kevin Feige has already
said that he has the next four years
worth of Marvel movies planned solid
early prediction I think that he takes
the spider-man Civil War tactic where
one big character shows up in a
crossover film like Silver Surfer or
Reed Richards then eventually that
character gets his own spin-off film the
reason why I think Fantastic Four is
probably going to be one of the first
ones is is because the best thing that
Kevin Feige could do to prove to people
that this Fox Disney deal is gonna lead
to awesome things is to hit a home run
with Fantastic Four right out of the
gate so to speak because it does take a
couple years for these things that
happen like spider-man showed up in
Civil War it took another year for him
to get his own movie in homecoming
like I said assuming the clock starts
when the deal closes early next summer
that's when Kevin Feige can hire writers
to start working on this developing
those projects so the earliest we could
possibly see a Fantastic Four or an
x-men movie set in the MCU would be 2021
but it could take even longer if he just
wants to cherry-pick characters and put
them in the MCU movies that they've
already planned in the next four years
like black panther 2 Eternals Avengers 5
it's gonna be at least two years before
Avengers 5 drops too so if that's gonna
be the first movie that features an
x-men character then it's gonna be a
while no idea if they're gonna have to
rewrite guardians of the galaxy 3
originally my assumption was is that the
first film that they develop after
guardians of the galaxy 3 when they
start writing that script that
when they'll be allowed to include x-men
characters because the script for
guardians 3 had already been finished
before all this drama went down so a
little bit of that is up in the air but
just in general don't expect to see a
lot of those x-men Fantastic Four
characters pop up in the MCU till the
year after the deal closes which would
be 2020 so just let me know in the
comments what do you think about all
this what movie do you want them to
start with how do you want them to
introduce those characters I still think
that spider-man's Civil War tactic is
the best looks like weighed in before
you cannonball with all these characters
all those infinity war blu-ray bonus
features are starting to drop so I'll do
videos for that in the next couple of
days I think everything starts dropping
on Tuesday so just leave all your
requests in the comments below click
here for that surprise Teen Titans
Season 6 trailer and click here for more
new Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]